apple just revealed the new 2021 ipad
pro at their spring loaded event
and i've gotta say what they did with it
is absolutely
mind-blowing surprising me on multiple
fronts
and throughout the entire presentation i
can only think of
one thing apple seriously just killed
the rest of the tablet market that's it
rest in peace
i honestly have no idea how samsung
microsoft or any of the other tablet
makers are gonna recover from this but
before i get into how apple killed him
hit that subscribe button below real
quick to help us reach
600k subs and now i want to go through a
brief history of the ipad pro
because it wasn't always this good let
me explain the 2018 ipad pro blew
a lot of people's minds when it was
released but it had some major issues
that i addressed in my original honest
review
mainly limited software support for file
management
and the new usbc port making the
experience
a bit disappointing on top of that the
mouse support was
terrible even after they released the
first version of ipad os
and the display support was really bad
as well
at the time samsung's galaxy tab s5e
had mouse and cursor support that made
it very convenient to use
especially with the samsung dex feature
which made file management work
great and then the tap s6 came out
giving the ipad pro even more
competition
since samsung added a trackpad onto the
keyboard case
making it super convenient to use until
finally in 2020
apple released the brand new magic
keyboard case
with a track pad alongside the new ipad
pro
making it the best ipad experience we've
ever
seen especially since the improved
multitasking
file management and more in fact it was
so impressive that we started
recommending the ipad pro
magic keyboard case combo over apple's
intel based macbooks
which at the time were experiencing huge
butterfly keyboard
issues while the ipad pro had a touch
screen
even better performance and a completely
fanless design
and even when samsung released the tab
s7 the ipad pro continued to destroy it
in many different ways being the obvious
choice for a premium tablet
however the ipad pro still had issues
like being limited to six gigabytes of
ram on the base model
the display was still using the same led
tech from 2017
and external display support still
sucked
but even with those issues the ipad pro
was still
by far the best tablet to buy but
now apple has just put the final nail in
the coffin
the new 2021 ipad pro is so good
that you'd be crazy to buy any other
premium tablet
in that price range the thing that
absolutely blew my mind
is when tim cook put the m1 chip
into the ipad pro that was a hilarious
ad
i honestly thought that it was gonna be
the a14x
but they literally put a mac chip with
all of its extra mac related components
into a super thin and light tablet now
if you're expecting the performance to
match the other macs
don't because they're going to be
lowering the wattage of the m1 chip
so the ipad pro can stay cool and get
the same 10 hours of battery life as
before
but thankfully we can actually calculate
the performance
by using apple's own performance
improvement numbers
which are usually a bit conservative by
applying a 50 percent
jump to the previous ipad pro's a 12 z
chip cpu score
we can expect around 7042 multi-core
points in geekbench 5
which isn't that far off from the actual
m1 max
but forget about comparing it to a mac
watch what happens when we compare the
ipad pro
to the performance of other tablets the
future galaxy tab
s8 which might be coming within the next
few months is rumored to be coming with
the latest snapdragon 888 chip
which only scored around 3 400 points
in samsung's s21 ultra so based on that
the new ipad pro will quite literally
have more than double the performance of
the future tab s8
which is mind mind-blowing now moving
over to the graphics side
the ipad pro gets the full 8 core gpu in
the m1 chip
and apple says that we should be seeing
a 40 improvement in graphics
so if we take the 12 000 metal score
points that we got with the a12z
and add 40 we should be expecting close
to
17 000 points in the geekbench 5 metal
test
based on that the base m1 macbook air is
only around 10
faster than the ipad pro which isn't
that big of a performance hit
considering how thin the ipad pro really
is
and since the macbook air scored around
69.85 fps in the gfx bench
1440p aztec ruins off-screen test
we can expect the ipad pro to score
around 63.5
fps in that specific benchmark and then
if we take that number and compare it to
what the snapdragon 888 scored
within the s21 ultra we can expect
the ipad pro to be around 2.3 times
faster than the future tab sa so
just like that the ipad pro just buried
samsung's tab s8 which isn't even
expected to get released
until this august which is when the
previous two tabs came out
and don't even ask me about microsoft's
new surface pro
x with the sq2 chip which is even weaker
than the snapdragon 888 and the one
complaint that many ipad pro users had
in the past
is finally fixed we now get
8 gigabytes of ram on the base ipad pro
and up to 16 if you get a higher storage
model
so the ipad pro is now a literal
powerhouse
but wait there's more we're only just
getting started with the tablet
slaughter fast
the ipad pro is now the only tablet out
there
that comes with an actual thunderbolt
port
which is extremely impressive and opens
it up to a world of possibilities
first off you can now connect full speed
thunderbolt drives
like this sabrent one which we recently
reviewed
you can now connect high bandwidth
thunderbolt hubs and docs
like this crazy owc hub which gives you
a usb 3.2 port
and an extra two full speed thunderbolt
ports
as we've already tested and showed off
with our m1 mac mini
and of course the ipad pro now finally
gets
full external display support even with
the 6k pro display xdr which
is mind-blowing let's see if any other
tablet can make that claim
no they can't of course we have the
other new great features like the
optional 5g support
which is actually twice as fast as what
you get with the iphone 12.
better camera features like smart hdr3
and night mode
as well as the new ultra wide facetime
camera
with the center stage feature which i
think is great
because previously the webcam was way
too zoomed in on the ipad pro but by far
the most important feature is the brand
new mini led display
that comes on the 12.9 inch ipad pro
when apple announced this
it blew my mind even though i was
already expecting the mini led display
i did not expect a massive 1600 nits of
peak brightness
for supporting hdr content like hdr10
hlg
and even dolby vision with an amazing a
million to one contrast ratio
the reason this blows my mind is because
those specs
match up perfectly to apple's pro
display
xdr which by the way costs five
thousand dollars without the stand so
for just a hundred dollars more than
last year's 12.9 inch ipad pro
you're getting an m1 chip and a display
that matches the performance
of a five to six thousand dollar pro
display xdr
this means that actual professionals are
going to be buying the 12.9 inch ipad
pro
for color grading photo editing or
whatever else they want to do
even if it's just to use the display and
based on a leak from john prosser
i'm almost 100 sure that at this year's
wwdc
apple is going to be adding final cut
logic
and xcode or maybe even more apps to
the ipad pro which is going to be able
to use
all of that power and now comparing the
ipad pro's new mini led display
to the rest of the tablet market nothing
else can compete
yes the larger 12.4 inch tab s7 plus
has a really nice super amoled display
with a high contrast ratio and nice
colors
but there are a lot of downsides to oled
first off it doesn't get
nearly as bright only up to 430 nits
so it doesn't even give you true hdr
support
unlike 1600 for the ipad pro
and second you're going to be dealing
with issues like screen
flickering and potential display burn-in
issues as well but with the ipad pro's
new mini led display
none of those issues exist at all
because it's actually still using an lcd
panel but the back lighting is
redesigned
with over ten thousand mini leds
and over 2500 local dimming zones to
help
achieve that contrast ratio so in terms
of the display
the 12.9 inch ipad pro absolutely kills
any other tablet out there and i think
it's going to take them
years to catch up and even if you choose
to buy the 11 inch ipad pro
without the mini led display you're
still getting a
killer value for 800 dollars compared to
any other tablet
because of the performance of the m1
chip the new thunderbolt port and
everything else
the only downside is that it's not going
to be coming out until sometime
next month but if you want to see us
compare it to other tablets and even
m1 max definitely click that circle
above to subscribe
for those videos and more like that and
definitely check out those two videos
right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video